you know I recorded the intro before
this bad and had the mic on [ __ ] [ __ ]
doing this over again I don't feel like
it who's walking upstairs you guys are
making trebles hey what is going on
YouTube now you know me if you send me
topics and you send me articles on
though ticket ticket talk about it yeah
what did I say like that
now according to sources a man was
caught having sex with a horse for the
third eye and in the process it broke
his leg in other words this man is a
horse [ __ ] it's very rare that I will
read an article online and have it give
me an epiphany that's right I know big
words Epiphany it's a it's the name of a
of my sister's friend Epiphany you know
how we use a lot of phrases in our
everyday conversations without realizing
where it comes from for example the
phrase mother [ __ ]
in order for that phrase to have existed
[Music]
now jr. we know why people call each
other horseback or ping Zhi Bao Calero
it goes up Josh you [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
what is your fascination with horse
[ __ ] why why it must be the goddamn
horse booty it must be because you will
probably watching one of them horses
with those big-ass rifle booties
bouncing up and down thinking oh even
that you can either look at that
muscular booty in my face and of course
you know for those of us out there that
aren't too knowledgeable about first
[ __ ] one must ask you why why is it
really that hard for you to find a human
being to have sex with because I don't
buy that [ __ ] and in fact it turns out
that most self-identified animal [ __ ]
say that is not because there aren't any
other options it's because it's a sexual
preference which I personally believe
because it has to be 10 times harder for
you to butt-fuck a horse because you
have to calm her down first
take her out to eat treat her special
building relationship of trust it's not
something that different [ __ ] and on top
of that I want to know what was a
pick-up lines that you used as an
icebreaker a book that you want to
guaran at my D or C we're going to [ __ ]
and trust me you won't say nay
hey what's the I heard you were looking
for a babe or relationship took me six
hours to figure those jokes huh
[ __ ] you shit's funny and you guys want
to know what the saddest thing about all
this is when the authorities were
notified about him and they found him in
the barn his excuse was that he got hit
by a car and he crawled into the barn
for shelter
[ __ ] you are looking for shelter you
was looking for horse butter and you
found it tell me why is it that every
person that is caught doing something
wrong absolutely sucks at lying
you were being a lying and doing crap
will go hand in hand but that's the
skills test that you don't have done
[ __ ] if you weren't going to lie about
[ __ ] a horse your [ __ ] at least has
to make sense you have to have nerves of
steel when you're caught because your
life sounds like some [ __ ] that you say
after your Helen ervice were you [ __ ]
my courses what because like Nick came
down and then Zeus was like a man is
chilling the Barna should hear something
we'll have some crackers whatever stay
here I didn't [ __ ] horsies no yeah you
[ __ ] my horses yes I did have sex with a
horse for the man [ __ ] [ __ ] could you
not say anything today it'd make me
phrases in our everyday conversations
but I would the canal oh god damn it